The joe rogan experience.
She's been on the road.
Not really,
I mean a little bit here and there and stepped back from Baltimore
satellite.
It was fun later for the UFC,
so,
okay.
Oh yeah.
Thanks for the offer on our land.
Dismissed you there.
We were out of there about four days before you made a great,
well,
you know that guy cow had in Tampa.
Okay,
great.
Did said he,
he decided he syndicating,
so he decided that he's gonna change his name to his real name is might call
tech.
So you get rid of cow head.
Right,
right.
Well,
so they did a roast for him as it was a benefit,
but the idea was that everybody was saying like,
this is your only fucking equity of like,
dude,
you know.
And so,
uh,
so it was me,
Jim Norton,
Bert Kreischer Florentine,
um,
uh,
Bobby Kelly,
we all flew down for it.
No Shit.
Yeah.
But they said,
you know,
come down and uh,
from your family will be tickets to every theme park.
We stayed dead.
That's a scratch.
So,
um,
so we went to universal days.
They push guards all with like the fast pass or you go to the front of the line.
Got Us great hotel fluid solve in.
Oh it was great.
And then my sister was down in Florida visiting my mom's.
So then we just,
we made a vacation and I spent a week at my mom's after that.
So it was a good trip.
Yeah.
But I,
I fucked it.
Tweak my neck on some relativists digital really bad knees.
Busch gardens is like,
if you're into roller coasters,
it's,
they've down like it does enough,
the most hardcore roller coasters and the country and they're like 400 foot
straight drops and corkscrews and you know,
and I was into it,
but down on the second to last one I felt something.
And then I spent at my mom's house,
I literally this,
this is my rotation for the entire week at my mom's house,
man.
I went to the chiropractor twice.
If that ever happens,
forget the our Mukund deep tissue massage.
Yeah,
loosen up to soft tissue.
That's almost all.
But really,
yeah,
I mean,
and I've had come through a series of back injuries over the last year,
and one of the things that I've found is a lot of chiropractic is bullshit.
Why?
And Not really recognized by science or medicine either.
It's a broad word design.
Even one type of chiropractor.
You get guys that you all different kinds of shit.
Yeah.
The guy who went to wasn't great.
I just felt like I needed something.
I was going to get a massage bits place in town is clearly I would fell.
It's just too weird to do that with my staff on my mom's
home.
Quite good.
No therapeutic.
Okay.
Don't walk on my back and it's gonna make it worse.
You read some indeed that,
yeah.
If,
if she's light is great,
but some of these fucking cows,
they're,
you know,
they're 50 years old and I put on a few pounds,
like just,
we am good.
Yeah.
I went to a time slash place.
They did that.
Okay.
Yeah.
High school fee is a little Asian.
That's my thing.
Here's the thing,
what a weird thing.
It's just so random.
Suck.
Right?
No,
I don't sir.
Take a lot of handed packs and you start getting depressed and it's uh,
it's the dirty secret of combat sports that most of those guys,
when you hear all that positive talk,
it's not just a pump themselves up for fights.
It's tough to try to push away the demons.
Sure.
That are in their consciousness because of depression.
And the other thing that goes along with that,
a lot of times they'd rather combative and argumentative.
That's a way of getting serotonin levels go on,
creating some type of little argumentive thing and then he'd get like,
oh,
the accompany right hormones ago along with that argument of nature.
Yeah.
Like me right now,
like I'm all fired up above his fucking yeah.
Yeah.
But you didn't have a likable,
you didn't take the punches to the head like no.
Yeah,
there's no punches to the dead.
And I was just reading today about this whole dirty drug thing going on in the
NFL,
how they just pumped these guys pull up painkillers for years and all lady came,
oh yeah.
Parking set everything.
If I could in and I mean just on and on and on and just tons of this stuff and
these guys are suffering.
We know failure,
so it's horrific,
horrific,
horrific stuff.
I mean,
I don't know if you had a son but you want him to play for,
I would not have that happen.
Fight.
I'd rather have my kid fuck cause I think that's a teacher.
Kids judo,
any day over football and you could fight intelligently and you could have a
good camp.
Let's listen.
We could talk about that on the podcast.
Yeah,
that's actually a good thing.
Let's do it Jeremy.
Yeah,
I mean it's brutal now.
There's like over 500 players suing the NFL.
Yeah.
What's talking about that?
Let's talk about that.
Has the drawback changed?
It makes it a little bit slower.
It's such a powerful photo.
It doesn't matter,
but it makes it more accurate.
It makes it easier to,
as long as,
yeah,
they got a national,
she's,
yeah,
no totally.
This is different but it's super accurate because of that.
What I have to do.
The reason why I brought it here as I have a chronograph and the back that tells
me the exact speed and then you have to calculate how fast he,
uh,
the car was going to travel and that will let you put in what's called a sight
tape site
piece of equipment,
like a work of art.
This is a pretty rare one because this is a 90 pound bow hold back or 90 pound
bow.
So it's very rare
they don't make them.
So I see the way it's curved.
So you can only pull it back with one.
I can pull up with your right.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
This is a stabilizer,
attach this on to it nicely and then wants to stabilize
this,
this
site.
Yeah.
This is the stabilizer.
This sort of helps balance it out while you're shooting.
And this year that's a site.
This is a hell of a weapon.
Yeah.
This is no joke.
Well,
my thought is if you're going hunting you,
um,
well you really helped me.
Yeah.
You really should use the most powerful thing that you can and did.
The issue really is that a lot of people think,
you know,
hey,
if you know you don't need that kind of power.
And they,
there's a lot of criticism in the bow community,
the archery community of people who use like really heavy pound bowls,
they think that,
you know,
you're being a meathead and it's not necessary and you're,
you're over bode,
you know,
you don't need that much bow.
But
I've kind of thought that through.
I think what's a regular guy?
What strong to a regular guy is not that strong to a person who lives a lot of
weights.
Yeah.
For sure.
Straight as revenue.
Yeah.
For me to use a 90 pound ball and a guy who is weak to use a 60 like why does he
think that?
That this is harder for me to use it.
It is for him to use a 60 like if you don't lift a lot of ways.
Yeah.
So,
but it's so weird.
Like he,
it's,
it's weird,
this ego thing that goes on,
it's weird criticism thing like,
oh that's old.
That's great guy.
You don't need that.
Why do you use that?
You don't need to,
but I really think it's because they can't do it.
So they have this weird thing there have,
I personally wouldn't want to go.
That would be as powerful as I could possibly 12 but yeah.
Well come on over here.
I'll show you how you use the chronograph in worse than maybe an animal.
Can I put the site tape on his,
that was his,
his 20 yards.
Yeah.
This from here.
All right.
From this,
he's pretty far off man.
No real shot or Vr.
It's really weird.
Is any movement at all
football?
This is cause we're in the door.
Yeah.
So there's a lot of trial and error.
So lots of really long shot then.
What's that?
What's a real long shot?
I mean what's considered a long longtime?
Anything over 40 the real,
real marsh or real archer
just keep that's right.
Yeah.
So I'll do this for hours once I get home.
This is kind of shooting her name.
[inaudible]
yeah,
once you get,
once you get the swing of it.
So interesting.
Because one year cross train on the shot,
once you're locked in,
the world goes away.
[inaudible].